l'année 2016 en europe et en france
qu'est-ce que fort de ressembler à
l'année 2015 dans ce sens qu'on risque
de voir à nouveau des attentats des
attentats qui pourrait s'élargir
maintenant à d'autres pays
les allemands les belges s'en sont rendu
compte avec effroi le 31 décembre
ils sont aussi maintenant en première
ligne et le savent les français se sont
beaucoup plus vulnérables maintenant
surtout au lendemain des attentats du 13
novembre
on sait en 2015 des services de
renseignement ont réussi à déjouer pas
mal de tentatives d'attentats la chance
il ya été pour beaucoup puisqu'ils ont
eu affaire à des apprentis terroristes
parfois maladroit ce qui a permis
d'éviter souvent le pire la chance
qu'ils jouent pour beaucoup et la chance
ne sera probablement pas toujours du
côté des forces de renseignement en 2016
on le sait ça a été dit à plusieurs
reprises pour remplir leur mission avec
succès à les services de renseignement
doivent être chanceux tout le temps
alors que pour réussir et terroristes
n'ont besoin d'être chanceux qu'une
seule fois